nach golde drängt am golde hängt doch
alles
johann wolfgang von goethe im faust gold
seit jahrtausenden ein mythos
wegen seiner schönheit und seiner
beständigkeit war gold schon in ägypten
begehrt auch weil es so selten ist ist
es für könige das zeichen von macht und
erhabenheit gewesen
krösus könig von lydian dies bereits im
sechsten jahrhundert vor christus die
ersten münzen aus reinem gold prägen
dieser film zeigt ihnen wie sie heute
mit gold sicher durch die krise kommen
während papiergeld kommt und geht wird
gold nie seinen glanz verlieren
[Musik]
seit über 5000 jahren ist gold die
beständigste anlageform überhaupt zuerst
als tauschmittel später um das siebente
jahrhundert vor christus herum als
geldmünze mit einer goldmünze konnte
jeder überall einkaufen und tauschen für
jeden menschen war gold als wertvolles
metall anerkannt gold ist unzerstörbar
es ist nicht beliebig vermehrbar und es
ist selten
heute existieren vom weltweit gewonnenen
gold ca 153.000 tonnen
dies entspricht einem würfel von 20
metern kantenlänge
auch das erste papier geld war mit gold
hinterlegt jeder inhaber eines
geldscheins konnte diesen gegen gold
eintauschen erst im ersten weltkrieg
wurde dieser goldstandard die koppelung
des papiergeldes an gold aufgegeben
dadurch erst wurde es regierungen
ermöglicht geld aus dem nichts zu
schöpfen
die hyperinflation der 20er jahre ist
genau aus diesem grunde erst entstanden
heute sind sämtliche währungen dieser
welt vom gold abgelöst
die finanzkrise hat unmengen an frisch
gedrucktem geld hervorgebracht dagegen
kann gold niemals pleite gehen
[Musik]
wer gold kaufen möchte kann das auf
verschiedene weise tun
es gibt die vier möglichkeiten
goldzertifikate von banken exchange
traded funds kurz etf aktien von
goldminen und physisches metall in form
von münzen und barren
viele banken haben seit den 80er jahren
den physischen verkauf von gold immer
weiter abgebaut
viel einfacher und lukrativer ist es für
diese banken gold und silber nur auf dem
papier zu verkaufen
nichts anderes ist ein zertifikat eine
schuldverschreibung bei der die bank von
der differenz von an- und verkaufspreis
profitiert meist ist überhaupt kein
edelmetall hinterlegt das größte risiko
besteht aber darin dass sich die
garantien nur auf das produkt und nicht
auf den emittenten beziehen
das heißt geht der emittent pleite wird
das zertifikat wertlos
seit der pleite der lehman zertifikate
kann nur gelten finger weg von dieser
hochriskanten anlagen
exchange traded commodities etc und
exchange traded fonds sie und ähnliche
produkte gelten als die moderne art in
gold und silber zu investieren
das sind indexfonds die in physisch
hinterlegte rohstoffe investieren
ein etf oder eine etc wie der xetra gold
der deutschen börse hat einen enormen
zulauf im herbst 2009 waren fast 33
tonnen gold hinterlegt der anleger hat
einen anspruch auf das physisch
hinterlegte gold und kann sich dieses
sogar ausliefern lassen
mittlerweile gibt es viele rohstoff etf
vorteile einfache investitionen in
rohstoffe aller art keinen
ausgabeaufschlag der preis ist
transparent er ist gebunden an den
tagesaktuellen kurs des zu grunde
liegenden rohstoffs und die lagerung
entfällt für den anleger allerdings hegt
auch ein etf das emittentenrisiko
wenn die krise eine bank in die
insolvenz treibt ist nicht bei jedem etf
sicher ob der anleger sein investment
wiedersieht
eine goldmine in afrika die nachfrage
nach gold ist ungebrochen
jahr für jahr fahren goldminen weltweit
gewinne ein
gleichzeitig werden aber immer weniger
neue vorkommen entdeckt gold wird also
immer seltener
anleger können von diesem boom
profitieren meist ist hier die rendite
größer als bei einem invest in
physisches gold
der hebeleffekt liegt bei mindestens 1
zu 3 zum goldpreis neben barren und
münzen ist das das einzige investment in
reales gold und zwar in gold das noch im
boden ist und noch gefördert werden muss
für neueinsteiger ist es allerdings
schwierig minenaktien richtig
einzuschätzen
faktoren wie die geologie das management
die finanzierungen und das politische
risiko im jeweiligen land beeinflussen
den kurs dieser aktien
die auswahl von goldminenaktien ist
nicht einfach und daher etwas für profi
investoren zudem rentiert es sich wegen
dem zeitaufwand für kleinere summen
nicht
einer unze gold genau 31,1 gramm
ein sogenannter krügerrand aus südafrika
im gegensatz zu den anderen investments
sind sie bei barren und münzen auf der
sicheren seite
gold besitzt einen inneren wert und wird
niemals ganz wertlos
schon im neunzehnten jahrhundert bekam
man für eine unze gold einen guten
herrenanzug
auch heute entspricht das in etwa diesem
wert in diesem zeitraum sind
gleichzeitig viele papiergeldwährungen
und papier investments völlig wertlos
geworden hier zum beispiel 1 milliarden
dollar schein aus simbabwe oder hier ein
geldschein über 50 milliarden reichsmark
ein goldbarren geht niemals pleite
folgende grundsätze sollten sie beim
kauf von physischem gold beachten je
größer der barren oder die münze umso
geringer ist der preisaufschlag das
heißt der kaufpreis liegt dann ganz nah
am reinen metallwert dieser unterschied
von ankauf und verkauf mit spread
genannt anlage oder sogenannte bouillon
münzen eignen sich besser für ein
investment als sammlermünzen bei
sammlermünzen wie hier aus dem
kaiserreich zahlen sie einen bestimmten
sammlerwert mit dieser hat mit dem
reinen metallpreis gar nichts zu tun
gold ist die konzentrierte form einer
physischen anlage auf relativ kleiner
fläche konzentriert sich hier ein sehr
großer wert
damit können sie notfalls auch überall
hin flüchten
zu den wichtigsten anlagemünzen zählt
der südafrikanische krügerrand es ist
die weltweit bekannteste und beliebteste
anlagemünze sie gibt es bereits seit
es gibt sie nur in gold auch in
kleineren einheiten ein zehntel ein
viertel und eine halbe unze
der maple leaf die weltweit
zweitwichtigste anlagemünze aus kanada
charakteristisch das ahornblatt auf der
rückseite der american gold eagle bei
einer unze ist ein nennwert von 50
dollar eingeprägt aber wie bei allen
anderen münzen ist dieser nennwert eher
symbolisch natürlich ist diese unze gold
am goldpreis ausgerichtet
die wichtigste europäische
der wiener philharmoniker ihn gibt es
erst seit 1989 damals noch mit einem
nennwert in schilling
sie ist die einzige anlagemünze deren
nennwert auf eur lautet
weitere wichtige boullion münzen sind
die britische britannien der lieber tat
aus mexiko der australische nugget der
chinesische panda anlagemünzen gibt es
in reiner form wie den maple leaf oder
den philharmoniker diese sind weich und
zerkratzen leicht sind aber bei
investoren wegen der reinheit beliebt
daneben gibt es gehärtete münzen wie dem
krügerrand oder den gold eagle diese
sind kratzfest und für den
alltagsgebrauch besser geeignet auch
wenn sie wegen der kupfer beimengung
etwas dunkler sind neben den björn
münzen gibt es noch nach geprägte oder
alte umlauf münzen wie den
österreichischen golddukaten mit 3,44
gramm gold oder den schweizer vreneli
diese sind alltags münzen und daher
gehärtet kein investor sollte auf solche
münzen verzichten da sie wegen ihrer
kleinheit und bekanntheit für den
alltagsgebrauch gut geeignet sind
ältere leute kennen sie noch was ein
unschätzbarer wert beim einkauf damit
ist diese goldmünzen kosteten im herbst
2009 als unzen stücke um die 720 euro
für größere investments eignen sich
goldbarren zu sehen sind in der regel
das emblem und der name des herstellers
das gewicht und die reinheit auch die
zentralbanken lagern ihr gold als barren
im barren konzentriert sich die größte
wert dichte da der spread gering ist
sind barren also preisgünstiger als
münzen für anleger eignen sich barren zu
100 gramm 250 gramm 500 gramm oder ein
kilogramm
grundsätzlich kann man sagen mit barren
wird man mit zunehmender inflation oder
gar hyperinflation nur sehr große dinge
wie immobilien oder firmen kaufen können
daher ist es unbedingt notwendig auch
kleinere münzen und silber zu besitzen
im gegensatz zu silber gibt es bei der
anlage in gold keine mehrwertsteuer
münzen und barren können anonym bei
händlern erworben werden
bis 15.000 euro werden käufe nicht
registriert informieren sie sich bei
welchen händlern sie gold kaufen
keinesfalls sollten sie gold bei
unbekannten händlern oder
undurchsichtigen shops im internet
kaufen dort tummeln sich einige schwarze
schafe
[Musik]
grundsätzlich gibt es für silber
ähnliche anlageformen wie bei gold
silber zertifikate ots mit hinterlegten
silberunzen oder barren aktien von
silberminen und münzen und barren die
wichtigsten silbermünzen gibt es in form
von unten oder auch als ein kilogramm
münzen hier der maple leaf als
silbermünze mit dem charakteristischen
ahornblatt
der american silver eagle
der australische kookaburra eine
attraktive anlage münze ist auch der
wiener philharmoniker
gleiches motiv wie bei der goldmünze und
sehr weit verbreitet nennwert ist hier
ein euro 50 er ist sehr leicht
erhältlich und preisgünstig früher
hatten die geldmünzen einen hohen
silberanteil auch hier kann man
investieren wenn man an solche münzen
noch herankommt zum beispiel zehn
österreichische schilling fünf
reichsmark aus deutschland wichtig bei
einer anlage in silber münzen fallen in
der bundesrepublik sieben prozent
mehrwertsteuer an
in österreich 20 prozent zudem gibt es
sogenannte münz barren von den cook
islands mit einem kilogramm oder fünf
kilogramm
diese sind rechtlich deklariert als
münzen mit nur sieben prozent
mehrwertsteuer in deutschland bei
silberbarren eignen sich als anlage die
ein kilogramm und fünf kilogramm waren
das volumen und das gewicht sind hierbei
natürlich wesentlich größer als bei gold
um durch die krise zu kommen empfehlen
sich für den täglichen gebrauch in jedem
falle er münzen eine unze ist schon sehr
groß
[Musik]
walter eichelburg er ist betreiber der
gold und krisenvorsorge plattform
www.geld.com in seminaren gibt er sein
fundiertes und über viele jahre
erworbenes wissen an interessierte
weiter im folgenden sehen sie
ausschnitte und original mitschnitte aus
einem seiner edelmetall seminare
er gibt diesen kontrolliert der zirka 50
bis 70 jahre läuft er wurde für
russische wissenschaftler nahmen nicola
kuhn wird in den 1920 jahren entdeckt
und quasi ist also das gebiet auch ein
abbau es ist das aufbauen gute zeiten
schlechte zeiten jetzt das heißt und das
bild hier stattfand worden dass kanada
er hat also dabei in vier jahren ist
seit ähnlich wie das jahr für jahr 2060
auf 70 jahre her
wie zuvor in den frühling hier letzten
schuljahr begonnen 19 49 1 348 mit der
währungsreform meter die macht begonnen
man ist ein wenig kredit vergeben flori
krisengerede revier bringen gute selbst
papier weiter in die zehnjährige zeit
war das ist 66 da hier das war ein
übergang unmerklichen und der kläger
nicht mit nicht dramatisch das heißt das
ganze hier so schön geworden und mehr
inflation noch mehr appetit gewinner
das heißt wohl mehr hier darum mehr
kredite vergeben
das 66 bis 1980 es gibt sie diese phase
ist gelaufen sie jetzt zehn jahre oder
gibt soll man hier vielleicht gute zeit
für die allgemeinheit inflationsrate
geholt wird das wachstum hohe einkommen
steigerungen massiv gestiegen
zwanzigfache zu haben man sieht wie
gegen werther hier steigen die zinsen
sind sachen die hochschule ideal und
dann hier der übergang in 19 80 war
übergang von cisco zusammen konntet ihr
herbst die sie seither 20 jahre dort von
1980 bis 2000 hier 2000 ungefähr war
oben der höhe wo der papa war damals wo
eine unze gold
ein 40 liter als einziges mal musste 14
unser gott her geführten dow jones --die
nicht hier oben als ein ein meter ist
ein mal gold
das heißt über gold ist damals bei
aktien und 40 fache gestiegen
das heißt wenn eine papier sind
auffallend dieses ausgelöst war 20 jahre
gedauert was diese gute zeit nicht für
alle ist sehr gut gelaufen dass es so
gut wie ganz oben weil nicht sind nicht
so gut sehen sie ja sieben millionen
hartz 4 und bringen uns weiter und wir
jetzt hat das ungarische beginnt der
kontakt winter das system zerstört man
einsteigen wo sie reingehen müssen hier
raus ist papier rein ins wohnzimmer
bringen ja wenn da ist geht wird
aufgebaut
das ist seit hier dauert wie ich sah
zehntel sozialen ein jahr haben wir
schon hinter uns jetzt einmal da
nächstes übergang derzeit 15 bis 22
jetzt zu ende geht es nach daten eingibt
inzwischen werde schon abgebaut
die ägypter versuchen das zu verhindern
versucht diese papier zeit zu verlängern
es geht trotzdem nicht warum jetzt wie
gesagt in der ersten hälfte des
produktes gustafsson firmen schulen wer
sagt du film irgendwie vergeben oder
genauen erneut positiv investitionen
obwohl die neue produktion das abzahlen
das ist ähnlich wie die ring hier der
zweiten hälfte da werden die schulden
aufgenommen viel spekulation und schon
beim mehr verspätete von kosum treten
sie schauen sie steht meisten griechen
krise und der prinz mit konsumenten als
er 20 jahre alt genauso dann beraten wie
die erfahrungen und reiter als auch die
politik gegeben mit sascha
ein zweijähriges hat alles vorbei und
man sage ich auch gerne schon etwas was
glauben sie wann der nächste wagen
bewerteten immobilie und 18 wie heute
auftaucht werden in erster kontakt
herbst da vielleicht in 50 jahren
vielleicht in 50 jahren weist wir ihnen
hier in den raum
wer das nicht mehr erleben dann der
erste bewertungen der immobilie und wir
18 wie heute haben nicht vorher
es hat das heißt es macht keinen sinn
durch zu dort durchzutauchen und
sozusagen
so war es wieder besser martinz hin
diese reserve mehr wer mag ist in
vitrinen wird es nicht besser
ja das ist dann sehr für juden
abgeschrieben werden regieren weil man
es nicht sagen
sie konnten ein haus kaufen
mit der subprime kredite ich kann ihn
verstehen mit meinem ist bode halle
milliarden dollar eine million dollar
kredit ist heute anschlag in detroit und
wille aber aufarbeiten lassen
echte depression dort zu hause dadurch
steigen die preise ins haus ist ca 5000
dollar 5000 dollar durchschnittliche
preis eines hauses
ich denke dies ist kein tor es gibt sie
bekomme aber auch völlig intakten
häusern 1000 dollar wenn sie lust haben
dort zu wohnen ist fiel allerdings nicht
schlechter beginnen können sie auch aus
tolle interviews auch 1000 dollar kaufen
das gebraucht auto kostet ca 1000 dollar
warum auto könnte wegfahren das haus
immobilie kann ist nicht wegfahren und
wenn die vandalen gekommen also
ausgeräumt haben das ist sie behalten
wir da eine dollar gibt es auch jetzt
sehen sie was sich unter schweizer
kredit macht jetzt lasst die straße
geworfen schließlich zahlen habe der
chef selbst eigene vision notice drauf
wir sind dadurch sind sie raus
normal haben die chance mit dem chef die
leute raus der meriva regierte ganze
zeit auf der straße so dass luft
ausgestoßen
es gehört der bank vorgelegt und das bei
uns passiert hier
ich glaube den restschulden
wahrscheinlich ist dagegen die
privatkonkurs dann sechs jahre zu acht
jahre
wenn sie getrennte wie das
existenzminimum
es ist auch eine mit dem gemein ich war
bis dahin verlassen reisen ab bis der
usa zum beispiel schauen was einfach
nicht so verhalten können infrastruktur
der fläche kenntnis erhalten dass sein
nächstes jahr massiv schon ein effekt
ist ein totalverlust das heißt sie ist
ein wert unter null
warum wir müssen es kostenpflichtig
entsorgen auch noch kostenpflichtig
unter nur warum wm einzugs kurz gesagt
das heißt dass auch nur eine finanzielle
fata morgana eine anleihe war das ein
and web business nichts gegen seinen
traum es ist sozusagen das sieht
es ist ein haus der repression
depression ich definiert einfach eine
depression josé sosa botox habe ich
erreicht
große depression 8% sie irgendwann wird
so in die große depression wie kommt
eigentlich mit dem staatsbankrott
übernimmt immer der reale sozialprodukt
her und nicht dass das diese fälschungen
verzerrte ganz wichtig da eine person da
viel länger als eine restlichen minuten
durch drei jahren knapp fünf jahren über
20 jahren mit die längste depression war
der kommunismus die 40er jahre gedauert
hat
aber ehrlich gesagt sind massiv ab das
heißt zum beispiel wieder so viele autos
sehen wir heute sind sie hatte unter
protest die fahrzeuge verstand von wir
sind 90 60 oder so massive wahrhaben was
sehen sie heute schon dass mir das
passiert doch hartz 4 und ähnlich ist
das gab es doch passiert und hartz iv
weg fällt es dann abspielt die zehn
millionen hartz-iv-empfänger plötzlich
nichts mehr haben die dann an meine
definition die komplexität ihrer
arbeitskleidung mit reduziert das heißt
man kann nicht nur als auslagern
die zu dieser beziehungen sie nicht mehr
zuverlässig sondern muss vielmehr selbst
machen aber gehört sich die
inflationsrate oder mehr ist sehr
verstehen die usa um über 20 prozent
auch deutschland hat über 20 prozent
wenn sie hartz 4 frührentner erzählt
aber dazu nehmen österreich in
österreich genauso
das geht nicht nur mehr sozialhilfe
sondern immer für pensionen so die
heilige kuh
es gibt zwei arten hat depression
irgendwie geht wer hält die eine ist die
deflationäre depression wien zur presse
ja alle alle werden wir untergehen
die inflationären jetzt alles möglich
sehr die 80 immobilien verfahren
massiven wert wie bisher sondern wie so
ähnlich wie in ist noch so auf 14
prozent
lisa sind die aktienkurse gefallen
auch für patienten kronen und auf ein
prozent in euro will die chronik glaube
oder abgewertet hat offizielle kurs
glaube dass der krone dort ist 150 ohne
beute haben wollen euro kostet 350 am
schwarzmarkt
aber ich werde diesen kontrollen
eingeführt haben das heißt alle
vermögenswerte verfallen arzt die
immobilien luxusgüter verfahren werden
ist übrigens privat ist sehr günstig
geworden
ja diese günstig geworden und dann
einmal der politik gekauft wurde
rolex uhr zu begegnen wir auch nicht
mehr los da gehen wir gleich verbiete
das heißt wenn sich mit ihrem gewinner
anderen gehen
das ist etwas wert jeder möglich geld
haben dann noch eine hartes geld nicht
alles ist sie habe die person ganz
harmlos sei aber klar geld bunkern sagen
bitte auf kaufen
das hier ist viel viel schlimmer viel
schlimmer
ich nehme eine hypo aktionäre depression
wo das geld der selbst verloren wie sie
das bild recht ist übrigens ein bild aus
dann als der 23 und deutschland kinder
spielen mit gilt birnen
da kommt unser verheizen also habe ich
gedacht na dann köpfte draufgemacht von
la merkel form obama und vor allem aus
china
wie gesagt hier zb das hier ist ein
banken- oder 5 million dollars hier war
die westliche profession die große das
gibt es jetzt verliert rasen werden ihre
velos haben in der zeit meines system
wenn die tat macht einfach weiter drückt
aber davor für das geht ganz genau dass
ich brauch das altpapier problem ist
dass der wert des geldes schneller
verfehlt als die eine einnahme einkommen
steigen
das heißt die leute steingart massiv
freiwillig not berufe die
lebensmittelpreise steigen alte
energiepreise steigen an
wenn man über bekommt dafür die löhne
steigen real nicht das problem melden
was die macher kräuter sind weiß dass
wir können uns da wir flüchten dann
später erfolgen über das erschwert wenn
sie anschaut dürfte das in die edit
dieser kooperation ist dann wenn niemand
gelten übrigens ist in bad gastein
monaten passiert man hat es wäre
aufgegeben warum wenn niemand sie werden
mir genommen hatten immer hat sie mir
genommen und wieder aufgegeben die
digitale dort mit fremd jahr
südafrikanische rand us dollar oder euro
wenn es das verbindet die eigene werden
muss sie aufgegeben haben
wie ist das steht uns bevor es geht nur
gedruckt auf dieser abverkauf bei und
gibt es depressionen und der angst nicht
warum look der pleitegeier auf den
banken einfach deswegen weil die banken
so mies investiert haben
ja das ist dabei die gleichen holen
müsste und ist einfach leider so
es werden hielt sie für die kredite
genauso wie die sind vergeben für
kurzweil für spekulation
ich will nichts mit gezeigt werden ich
bin wieder zurück hätte die 480
zurückgezahlt werden
und genauso ich bin gerade diese
immobilie kann nicht zurückgezahlt
werden wenn eine immobilie massiv sinken
wie sie jetzt der fall ist
da ist irgendwas zu schwer
dann geht das ganze welt bankrott die
dritte gebiet sei glaube er stoppt inter
egal was die politiker sagen aber sie
sagen ja wir tun alles schiefgehen
zufrieden ins brötchen letztlich
politiker bestimmen darüber sondern nur
die banken eine bahre ungutes gefühl hat
nicht zurückgezahlt wird dann gibt es
einen kredit von jemand der nach drei
prozent eingabe der arzt zunehmend das
problem der zeitschrift die wirtschaft
dramatisch aber das heißt statt
integration jetzt in der stadt als
übernimmt und alles unterstützen werden
aus der deflation depressionen hypo
vorzunehmen
damals erinnern ja der mann den
geldeinwurf verhindert wird
das heißt es wird sich noch zwei sachen
verzichten
einmal auch lange gebiet orgelmusik
gerade letzten jahren erlebt haben was
die da die eigene häuser monat ist
übrigens nicht der zentralbank an etwas
monetisieren und verwandeln
jeder kann auch sie können sie können
ihr ausschnitt bisschen
sie können zum beispiel aber wenn sie
einmal gerade gemacht haben und diesen
kredit verkonsumieren recht machen
jeder kam und das sind problem ist nur
dass indien nachher müssen das wieder
zurückzahlen das problem ich bin starr
ist auch schon beim start hat einmal
geklappt
die staatsbank kurs das heißt lange
gewünscht müsste man verzichten und
kriegen natürlich kriegen sind verstehen
ist die treiber staatsverschuldung
moment brauchen wir gerade keinen krieg
unsere ganzen spiel ausreichen sollen
dafür wie gesagt das ist zu viel
verlangt dass jeder rezession 213 1 hat
man eine neu inszeniert april hätte
hätte preis 19 90 kommen müssen
man hat einen echten foto die
winterschläfer rausgeschoben einmal
aneinander die 280 und einmal 2001 2002
aber jetzt geht es nicht mehr aber es
kann schon uns spielraum ergibt immer
wird wie jesuit was zu schweren und dann
musst du kannst sie abgebaut werden die
übermäßige schulden
die nissan xtreme verbier vermögen ist
ja wie gesagt es war ein lang sind
eigentlich weg fehlinvestitionen über
große stadt die kritiker sehen das so
ich habe die gesellschaft sei der arge
da kommt dann sehen sie was also
dekadenz kind ist unglaublich ich glaube
ich einmal biete dieses system
gesundheit braucht das von zeit zu zeit
alle 50 jahre so dass wir alle 25 jahre
müsste ein richtiger depression her
alles auszuwaschen ist so
[Musik]
weiter viel besser sei es geld gibt
seine werte zweimal konnte der zug in
sommerphase wie einer steigenden
inflation
dies geht aus dem papier werden in
sachen in folge winter war es jetzt
dieses system zu stören
noch stärker das heißt nur essentielle
dinge erhalten wert einmal das neugeld
gold und silber neu gilt jetzt ist alles
legal wird wieder freigeben werden
das ist sicher dann wird dieser kurs
übergehen aber keine bilder mehr wenn
dieser gegen werden im inneren wert oder
wer in geld bringen ich wünsche ihr das
glauben geprägt werden
das ist ein mix aus kanada aus über
maple leaf weil die leute das kennen
einfach wie das geprägt die erste sache
ja der zweite sache ist lebensmittel
muss essen gute sache ist energie
betreibt die welt also nicht nur gegen
sachen sie vergessen luxusgüter
finanzmärkte täter waren wir jetzt keine
kredite mehr reden des pokerstars
kohlestrom er ist primär als
rettungsboot warum das löst das größte
problem ist es gibt es eigene
toilettenpapier ist oder zum heizen
entleerung 19 23
einzig unterschiedlicher art verkauf hat
noch nicht begonnen
ich mag sie dir nicht wie gesagt bei der
hypo fraktion und susi allen der alle
werte
es hätte größere retter das rettungsboot
ich glaube auch dass das die beste
lösung ist
und höchst wertzuwachs mehr als alles
andere
grund ist der beides regierte reichen
und sie über die damen die meisten leute
wie gold auf seinem höhepunkt der krise
wird eine unze kohl ein jahresabonnement
stellen nicht zu leisten dass silber mit
einem monatseinkommen darstellen
vermutlich sagen wir mal an kunden so
etwas gibt es hier alles gibt einmal
münchen barons hin trend investor gold
ist nichts im weg in berlin und kaufen
sie aktien immobilien solche sachen
musik karte das heißt sparen wären sie
nur gehen
wir hören zu mögen im leben sind sie
nicht da willst du diese überleben darf
beispiel die symbole münzen eine unze
reinisch gut und sie haben gab keiner
der interessenten ist staatlich geprägt
so quasi sozusagen als gütesiegel
aber sie bezahlen wenn wir dabei die
aufgedruckten wird das fluchen oder die
hand drauf sie euren gefährten dafür
drauf hier philharmoniker grüne 10 euro
er hat dafür zehn euro oder so das heißt
mein fehler ich nehme immer noch
pikanter münzen
das heißt deutschland wie gesagt können
sie nehmen
grüner hand philharmoniker können sie
nehmen gute karten in österreich selbst
verstehen den druck haben uns in der
schweiz einen freundlichen in der fremde
drinnen dunkles wie hier die 20 franken
haben das hier
ich weiß dass ich weiß dass gold geld
gehabt hat na ja da ist bin ich immer
einen wiederverkauf der existenz zu
gehen normalen menschen geben sie ihr
gold silber wir waren sie müssen den
wert erkennen nicht dass investor
alle menschen müssen erkennen ganz
wichtig das heißt möglichst keine exoten
das hätten ihm fehlen den bann da
empfehle ich nicht
zeitgleich zur münchner wiedererkennen
normale mensch nicht so es gibt es was
gibt es nicht alles geht einmal reine
bünzen sind wir hier dass man dann ja ja
ja es kann ein prozent der beliebten 18
und der philharmoniker da haben wir ganz
gleich wer zählt für uns in der 49
das heißt ist ein weiches gras leicht
ist irgendwo anders gebrauch geeignet
dann gibt es gehört wo wir müssen jetzt
mit dieser bürger waren also südafrika
13 prozent kupfer der berater eigene
musik wohl auch drinnen das größeren
dicker als der andere eine goldmünze der
herr ist gehört das ist als
alltagstauglicher viele wollen nicht
wahr er hat eine dunklere farben in
kupfer dann kann ich gold eagle der
zählung koffer dabei das ist ja jetzt
auch beliebter
deswegen fühlen sich einfach nicht
anders aber auch gesagt land wesentlich
besser geeignet da gibt es dann nach
vorne und ist schon einfach viel
fotografen irgendwelchen eigentlich nur
einfachen ja wir sind kaiser was sonst
oft nach träger von 19 auf 15 ist dass
in österreich sehr gut bekannt kann den
eltern wählen
absolut welche dieser 100 stück davon zu
1 grad wird ein monatseinkommen seien
340 gramm hat der in der schweiz
wohlgemerkt der fremde ist der fall wie
das auch gehärtet und in einer regierung
nur kupfer gewisser weise auch roth
wie gesagt da ganz kleine hier das ist
das ist der reine als klein ist reine
philharmoniker erzählte uns empfehle ich
nicht empfehlen demokraten
für montag ist ungleich größer
viel wichtiger als wir brauchen vom bund
hat es besser bei monika gott wie gesagt
dass sie das goldmünzen als überlebens-
gold immer ganz klein und am ende holt
sie eigentlich schon beim fiesta grund
es so toll sein wird nächste sieht die
silbermünzen nicht nur münzen gibt
verschiedene münzen zum beispiel sich
beim deutschen händler bekommen
beim silber bürger zum beispiel dass
kanada ist das ist kanal ist immer maple
leaf gibt neumünster auf kanada
australien kanada australien usa
österreich als beispielsweise silber
maple leafs über regeln alle nutzer von
kookaburra zum beispiel oder einer
anderen gibt es ein kilo für ein
kilogramm und auch weil sie zusammen
nach formen von teil 1 1 kilogramm 5
kilogramm 0 27 prozent mehr aussteller
in deutschland dieses rein investors
über so gegeben zu der zimmer wird
gesagt dass sie eine unzählige sowohl
die ein monatseinkommen sein das heißt
und wie bisher
kaufen sie gut bekannte münzen eine unze
relativ großer dank
dass sie aber noch etwas und zwar es
gibt diese es gibt diese alten münchen
zum beispiel maria theresien thalia
österreich dann die sie schon immer
jetzt entschieden zukünftig spielen ist
als österreich auf fünf gestiegen auch
das jetzt entschieden münze mit 73 es
wird vom 8 grad drinnen was meinen sie
die alten leute kennen sie noch in
österreich wohlgemerkt das heißt alle
österreich kann das nur empfehlen weil
es sehr viel davon gegeben hat dann gibt
es in deutschland keinen frieden diese
münze für freis machen dass dieser
bereich sein wohin sie hier hat 12,5
krams über drinnen weil es die prozente
aus den dreißiger jahren
der fünfte mann endlich gibt es auch die
selbst nicht auf den bereits
kommunizierten schwieriger kann ich nur
empfehlen da sie alle einnahmen kommen
sich beim unscheinbar der schweiz gibt
es für 1 franken stück agieren für alle
aufgekauft worden
ich sage auch keinen alltag auf nicht an
eine nutzung ist eine holt sich sehr
viel mit einem monatseinkommen zentis
schicht so warum sie sich das anbieter
zusätzlich bietet das an gold auf 1 ist
an dollar bereinigen einige werte ist
silber metallfirmen man stärker steigen
als golf sie wollen wir jetzt immer
stärker stellen als gut oder sie mal 10
mal
wir werden sehen das heißt die
essentiellen dinge wir lesen ihnen
energie begonnen das fünffache kosten
37 fahrer wir werden sehen die preise
sind wir nachziehen
das heißt nächste der kohle
silberbesteck auch die preise aller
lebensmittel und wir sehen dass jetzt
die hypo fraktion so das bringt die
massive verarmung massive warnung für
eine unze gold jahre dauern
der große steigern wenn sie haben über
heute finanziell aktien oder aktien
immobilien alle heute spielen kredit
abhängt dass sieg im preis zu typischen
nominell und vor allem nominalen
überlässt mit oder holt das heißt hier
und sie eine echte deflation über gold
sie erzählt der größe goldilocks aller
zeiten wird was werden wenn alles
umfragen noch viel ärger als in nevada
und kalifornien oder rats der regierung
was können sie machen sie können
entweder heute grund zu verkaufen was
empfehle und hat ihn aktien kaufen oder
das selbst gewaschen
das sind vier verschiedene ich nicht
margret sind die nachgeholten andere
machen sondern das tut man
man versorgt kleber zählten zum beispiel
in essen schaufeln unter durch alkohol
und uhren
dafür geben sie das meiste geld aus wenn
sie immer die hände beim reichen die
grippe selbst so und dies muss ich
wissen welche preise können sie rechnen
wobei es dann eine als erste preise hier
in deutschland österreich schweiz das
jetzt anders schweizer doppelte wenn sie
ein haus eine wohnung mieten und zum
gold bekommen offizier stück der frauen
bekommen sie ein haus eine wohnung in
usa bekommen es die zwei unzen gold
liegt vor mir dran
er ist lehrer in twitter bekommt
zusätzlich eine einigung zu trainieren
zu können hat schon eine sehr hohe
spaniens und bei spielen sie eine unze
gold
andere bieten wir gehen zum beispiel in
den doktorgrad der hund geholt
zugesagt eine kleine firma oder hotel
ein kilo leichter ist gold eine linie
werden wir wohl abwerten
das ist die normale menschen davon
nichts haben
wenn alles gilt für simyo leben braucht
man als kunde darüber was er tat zum
leben verdienen geht nur der wester der
seefahrt ein kilo silber wird ein haus
seien vermutlich jetzt der flugweite
mitzunehmen
das haus wurde zwar gibt es dann aber
wieder aufgegeben auch heike thiemann
und sieht man seite schreibt ja wenn du
kannst nicht zu wild wird mit steuern
als dann braucht das gebaren münchen in
den socken haut ab das heißt es versuche
daraus zu machen
das automobil das immobilien damit
könnte abkommen aus nicht das kann man
nicht steuern dann auch das steinbuch
möglich machen
warum bei uns über 300 jahre lang was
geld installation wird vor teilweise hat
immer noch stark geprägt die leicht
transportable hohe wert dichte aber
wirklich alle ansonsten eigentlich
immobilien teilbaren verderben nicht
dass er gegen die inneren werden keine
krauter baden weitergehen kann
bei bankeinlagen haben sie diese
counterpart gebannt und bei mir gerade
den start
beide gehen das ist das niveau der
rettungsboote gegen untergehen biegel
wir möchten feststellen dass wir keine
finanzberater sind und daher keinerlei
konkrete empfehlungen oder angebote für
investments oder finanzierungen machen
wir sind auch mit keinem anbieter von
investment oder finanzierungsprodukten
in irgendeiner form liiert alle inhalte
dieser dvd sind daher als völlig
unverbindliche information anzusehen und
keinerlei anlage oder sonstige
finanzierungs empfehlung wir verkaufen
oder vermitteln auch keine finanzanlagen
kredite oder finanzierungen jegliche
haftung irgendwelcher art für den inhalt
oder daraus abgeleitete aktionen wird
ausdrücklich und vollständig
ausgeschlossen das gilt auch für den
inhalt und alle links in den
ausgegebenen unterlagen bitte wenden sie
sich für rechtlich verbindliche
investitions oder finanzierungs
empfehlungen an einen lizenzierten
finanzberater oder eine bank
[Musik]